بما ان صباح العربي هو صباح السعاده دائما
طلبنا من الناس في السعوديه ان يروا لنا
نكته
قديمه ايش طلعوا وياهم خلينا نشوف
[موسيقى]
طيب يقول لك مره في واحد يبغى عنده سياره
قديمه ويبغى يبيعها ومنو عارف وما حد قاعد
يشتريها سال صاحبه القديمه قال له بسيطه
حط علامه مرسيدس على السياره وهي تنباع
قام قال له بعد اسبوع شاف السياره معه قال
له انت تستهبل في احد مرسيدس
ههه باله طويل راح الخياط قال ابيك تقصره
قال نمله هرقي فوق ظهري يبي يطلب من السوق
لما الفيل الرقبه فوق ظهر النمله ما جاني
شيء لما قالت انا دوري انا اللي برقه جت
النمله رقص فوق ظهر الفيل ومات انكس بس
كنا نضحك عليها على اساس ان تناسب عقليتنا
طبعا في واحد
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات